scp-096 versus scp-3166  who comes out on top between the  brutalizing shy guy and the horrific  lasagna-filled garfield creature let's  find out  scp-3166 is a creature resembling a  mascot costume of the character garfield  that attacks critics of the franchise  through severe bodily harm or the  force-feeding of lasagna in a  theoretical test between the two  anomalies garfield creator jim davis  would accidentally see a tiny fraction  of scp-096's visage without us knowing  scp-3166 would manifest to ensure that  nothing happened to the garfield strip  potentially stopping 0-9-6 on the other  hand scp-096 has the durability to  withstand high-grade foundation  equipment with striking speed to match  scp-31  couldn't defend itself against such a  fast and powerful opponent no matter how  much lasagna it tried to shove down the  shy guy's throat sorry garfield looks  like it's a monday for you